guys it's perhaps no surprise that some
of the most exciting plays and league of
legends happen in and around somebody's
base I mean come on what gets your heart
pumping more than an all-out brawl
around a dying Nexus or a last stand
against a wave of minions and five enemy
champions in your own face right now for
this list you got to know we did not
include backdoors because frankly we're
gonna do our own top ten backdoor list
in the future now let's get on with it
with this list something we're calling
the top 10 Nexus close calls starting us
off at number 10 is h2 Ches 2016 EU LCS
summer split match against FC schalke oh
for after winning an intense fight in
the barren pit
chocka went straight for h2 case-based
to take on a buff yang coast before
moving on to their Nexus as they turned
their attention towards the Nexus h2
Ches members started to respawn and
engaged in a crazy team fight
[Applause]
you just keeps delivering hold on the
strain at number nine we've got gamba
gaming's magic and CLG from the grand
final of IEM season 9 cologne already up
one game in the best-of-five gambit or
on the hunt but 52 minutes in they
realize that CLG was going to the
backdoor and well gambit stormed their
way up mid lane and quickly ripped
clg's based on the Ostia
really fast with this jack we see a
recall from okay CLG are going free on
the bottom side but they're already on
the Nexus
any tell Extreme Masters Cup final at
number eight we have Giants gaming's
2018 EU LCS spring split game against
h2k after 50 long minutes Giants gaming
decided to take the fight right to a
retreating h2 k's doorstep to the base
it looks like I may just be enough time
but suck me the fight is start to break
out there looking for a chance to break
this one back Betsy's in the middle of
everybody and he's not going to take it
down quite yet shared each 2k and other
points
[Applause]
coming in at number seven is Jen G's
match against Griffin from the 2018 lck
summer split after a vicious teamfight
on Jen G's doorstep left their Nexus at
1/4 health the team prepared to finish
Griffin off well did they know
Griffin's mid-laner trophy was making
his way through the jungle with his
sights set on Jen G's Nexus it was a
close call but genji players took out
trophy with only a few pixels of health
left on their Nexus while the remaining
players with the final nail in playoffs
but it feels like playoffs and gingi
dumbfounded find the victory at number 6
we've got g2 eSports game against
vitality from the 2016 EU LCS spring
split g2 brought vitality Nexus within a
single Auto Attack of Destruction not
once they're taking their time first
running laps trying to dodge out the
bombs pavel on the way in trying to
create the space necessary expense of
the house what light
he just needs to are they set to but to
place tried install at the pressure
fifty throwing down autos as well will
he did are they here all it takes the
single take double kill for police
though members of dropping vitality
managed to hold them off close times and
G twos inability to finish off the Nexus
would be their demise at number five is
SK gaming's group stage match against
counter logic gaming at Worlds season
two in what was shaping up to be a close
game the two teams battled hard and just
as things started to tip in eske's favor
clg's doublelift went for their Nexus
boy boy quickly joined him and SK had no
choice but to come back and fight them
after they failed to take out their
Nexus turrets more boy managed to stay
alive amidst eske's defense and to hook
out their Nexus with only a few pixels
of health left to spare
[Applause]
at number four we have a matchup between
fnatic and oMG from the world's 2014 the
Europeans went toe-to-toe is China's oh
my god but one hour into the 71 minute
bloodbath saw fanatics minions going to
work a few minutes later fnatic top
laner so has attempted to backdoor a
distracted OMG
so as is rallying cry initiated a
barrage of fanatic players rushing down
the nexus artillery he's going to stop
sign he has to one of the big damage
dealers go going is gonna make it in
that gaze there here comes syenite as
well on the end they're focused on the
guardian angel lasagnas ten cyanide
flippin as this Oh will they be able to
get it Peck they up from the guardian
angel Gilmore heads and six minutes and
eleven kills after that oh my god
destroyed fanatics Nexus pressure OMGs
guardian angels up going headfirst in
that fight to the down guardian angels
on the side of fnatic
on those deaths pawns as their Nexus
goes down and
oMG mix up the win over banana coming in
at number 3 we have counter logic gaming
taking on Team solomid at MLG Anaheim
2014 after wiping CLG TSM headed
straight for their Nexus but little did
they know they weren't entering a base
race with CLG they were joining one with
[Applause]
despite dyrus his best efforts the
minions were simply too much for TSM's
Nexus to handle the minion wave respond
a little bit of time in 60 minutes the
minions backdoor the base
I don't like to say and our runner-up
spot is cloud nine taking on samsung
blue during world's 2014's quarterfinals
on the topic of win in samsung blue let
them go to work on c9 s Nexus as the
North American squad were pushing
Samsung while it looked like c9 would
squeak out a win on s ESPYs doorstep the
Korean squad proved too much for cloud 9
to handle they have the team after a
quick ace they managed to take the NA
hopefuls Nexus and move through to the
semi-finals taking the number one spot
on our list is kt rolster game against
Invictus gaming from world's 2018 the
Chinese hopefuls were already up two
games on the Koreans but Katie would not
go down without a fight
Jackie take it down - got a double look
at find even more let's take it down to
go to mana get away
the two teams exchanged blows on both
sides of the mat with a team fighting
the red side base and a 1v1 in blue what
followed was a battle between two
juggernauts fighting for their
tournament lives it's Katie looking
trying to stand and fight if they can 81
they prevented the sweep and ended up
bringing the series to five games before
losing to the eventual tournament
champions okay guys that's all we got
for you on top 10 this week now do me a
favor
auto-attack that comment section and hit
the like button like it's an enemy Nexus
with a pixel of health and I'll see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button